no they won't tell us they won't tell us
a thing until the scripts come out for
the season
while many actors are happy to stay with
a popular show for the long haul
some would rather jump ship and make
sure they never come back
you guys want to pay a visit to the
crypt keeper that's fine it's your
business but
keep me out of it it's pretty rare for
an actor to be down for the more
permanent option of their character's
own demise
but they usually have a good reason
let's look at the bold performers who
did just that
seem to rid myself of you actor paul
wesley starred as vampire heartthrob
stefan
on vampire diaries as the series was
wrapping up
wesley and his on-screen brother ian
summerhalter requested that their
characters perish together
we wanted the brothers to go out with a
bang together but in the end
only wesley got his wish in the finale
stefan heroically sacrificed himself
giving summerhalters damon the cure to
turn back into a human
and a happy ending with elena oh my god
you guys did it already didn't you
playing spencer in pretty little liars
troy and belisario actually tried to be
a victim of the show's mysterious
villain a she believed the story would
truly be treacherous if one of the
titular liars bit the dust
you're kidding me right but despite her
solid argument
spencer survived to the end of the
series sticking around has its perks
though as bellisario got to jump into
the director's role for one of the final
season's episodes cut
actor kyler lee portrayed meredith
gray's half-sister lexi
on the long-running grey's anatomy but
after an extended hiatus to spend more
time with her young family
she approached showrunner shonda rhimes
to work out an effective end to her
character
in the season 8 finale lexi succumbed to
injuries she sustained in a plane crash
however lee made a surprise return to
the role in season 17
joining meredith on a magical beach as
she battles covid in real life
i don't know cooper scooper that's a bad
nickname
misha barton starred as marissa on the
oc
partway through season two barton became
overwhelmed with the bloated shooting
schedule
and didn't feel protected on set so in
the season three finale
marissa succumbed to her injuries
following a car crash
after ryan carries her from the fiery oh
okay
oh wow it's a lot of fire ben mckenzie
who played ryan was admittedly confused
by her sudden departure
very odd to the to to have someone who
was
in it from the beginning i believe i'll
protect you i promise
no one can protect me in the lead-up to
season six
game of thrones's sophie turner who
portrayed sansa stark
made her hopes for her character's fate
crystal clear how would you sort of wrap
up your character's story
i don't want to survive she argued that
if you didn't go out in a memorable
blaze of glory
then what was the point in the end much
like game of thrones fans
turner didn't get her way surviving to
the very end of the series
there's no smoking why not oh my god
you're in a hospital starring as dr
george o'malley on grey's anatomy
tr knight became frustrated with his
lack of screen time and limited
communication with showrunner shonda
rhimes
and asked to have his character taken
care of despite the perceived tension
dr o'malley went out a hero he jumped in
front of a bus
for me knight even made a surprise
return
in season 17 also joining meredith
grey's magical beach
storyline sounds like all is forgiven
on game of thrones veteran actor julian
glover played the crafty pycelle
who suffered a cruel fate at the hands
of lord varus little birds in season six
but before the final season aired glover
revealed that his character's fate was
exactly what he wanted
glover was no longer interested in
playing the role of cersei lannister's
verbal punching bag
and he couldn't be prouder of pycelle's
final moments
which is a damn good scene it's a damn
good scene and
this is exactly the sort of way i wanted
to go out men are evil
will you go with me former wand division
star emma caulfield's first entry into
fantasy action
was his thousand-year-old scooby gang
member anya on the 90s hit buffy the
vampire slayer
i dislike that anya she's newly human
and strangely literal
early into season seven it wasn't yet
confirmed that it would be the show's
final one
but caufield wanted to make sure that it
was hers season seven did in fact turn
out to be the last
but caulfield still got her wish falling
in battle to a harbinger of death in the
series finale
when kevin alejandro who portrayed
detective dan espinoza on lucifer
sat down with the showrunners ahead of
season 5. everyone assumed it was the
final one of the series
alejandro suggested that it'd be smart
if dan didn't survive
and the showrunners agreed having him
taken out by french hitman rob benedict
but when netflix swooped in and gave the
show a sixth season
alejandro asked to return maybe our dear
detective is making a deal with the
devil
jessalyn gilsig who starred as sikki on
vikings
approached creator michael hurst at the
end of season 2 and informed him that
she could no longer live overseas in
ireland where the series is filmed she
wanted to work a little closer to home
hearst listened to her request and near
the end of season three
ziggy drowned in an icy lake rejoining
her late husband and daughter in
valhalla
leading up to breaking bad's iconic
final season actor dean norris came to
creator vince gilligan with a specific
request
to bite the dust in the first half of
the season norris who played hank
schrader
had booked a pilot for a comedy show and
needed to be free of his breaking bad
contract in time to film it
gilligan turned him down and hank didn't
bite it until the second half of the
season
actor monica kina starred as snarky
troublemaker abby morgan
on the smash hit late 90 series dawson's
creek but
the show's wild success couldn't keep
her around
not long after debuting in season 1 kina
lost
interest in the teenage melodrama and
asked for abby morgan's demise
the showrunners indulged her and late in
season 2 abby morgan drowned after
drunkenly falling from a pier
to the icy water below you shoot me over
a truck
there's a lot of food on that truck much
like game of thrones
no one is safe on the walking dead but
actor tom payne disagreed
during season 8 payne who played jesus
no no no this jesus felt that there was
too many characters still alive on the
show
and even volunteered his own as tribute
the showrunners agreed
and in season 9 the charismatic leader
was run through by a whisper
actor raymond cruz portrayed tuko
salamanca the demented drug kingpin on
breaking bad
a character raymond did not enjoy
playing after his first stint
he was dismayed to learn that the show
wanted him back for another eight
episodes
cruz not only shut that down he begged
for salamanca's demise
they obliged with fellow list mate hank
schrader taking him down
but cruz did eventually reprise the role
and breaking bad spin-off
better call saul
i can protect myself actor crystal reed
starred as alison argent on teen wolf
but early into season 3 reed had felt
her time on the series had run its
course
i'm sad because it's also a part of me
that i have to say goodbye to later that
season
alison passed on after courageously
doing battle with an oni but
reed couldn't stay away for long
returning in season 5 as alison's
distant ancestor marie jean vale
while actors stephen young dan stevens
and ruth wilson were all interested in
leaving their respective hit shows
none of them explicitly requested the
violent and tragic send-offs they all
received
if you were a famous actor on a big time
series how would you want to go out
personally i'm riding off into the
sunset